اطلاق النار على دوريه اليونيفل ومقتل
الجندي الايرلندي تضيع على المشهد
اللبناني سياسيا وامنيا وفي محاوله
لاحتواء تداعيات ذلك توجه رئيس حكومه
تصريف الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي وقائد الجيش
الى الناقوره جنوبيه لبنان والتقى يا قائد
قوات اليونيفيل في زياره تضامنيه
والقضاء اللبنانيه والجيش اللبناني ما
يقوم به من تحقيقات في الوقت الحاضر هي
تحقيقات مستمره همم مستمره وسيكون نوع من
محاسبه كامله وكل انسان سيكون له عقابه
بهذا الموضوع
التي وقعت فيها الحادثه هي احد ما عاقل
الحزب السياسي هو النقد
حزب الله لقرار توسيع مهام قوات اليونيفيل
التي اصبح
الصلاحيه وفقه القرار مجلس الامن الاخير
همم تنظيم دوريات ااه من دون التنسيق مع
الجيش اللبناني او مع اي جهه على هذه
القاعده
ما حصل ردا لعده رسائل يريد حزب الله
ايصالها
ليس لاننا يعني نتحسس من طريقه اداءه
لمهامها بل نعتدي عليها من دون اي سبب وفي
هذا رساله مفتوحه لكل الناس انه اذا شئنا
ان نعتلي على اليونيفيل فالموضوع ليس
محصوره فقط بطريقه اداء المهام داخل ال-
ال- القطاع جنوب الليطاني اذا كانت مواكبه
من الجيش او لا واذا كانت مسموح ان تدخل
الى المناطق معينه او لا
هو بيحسبي معلومات العربيه فان اليه
اليونيفلم المصفحه الا ان الباب الخلفي
كان مفتوحا والرصاصه التي قتلت الجندي اتت
من الخلف خلال ملاحقتها بالنيران ما يدعو
الخبراء الى الاستنتاج بان هذه العمليه قد
تكون مقصوده بانتظار نتائج التحقيقات
يترقب لبنان زياره لوزير الدفاع الفرنسي
نهايه العام الذي سيتفقد قوته العامله في
اليونيفيل وما سيحمله في جعبته جراه هذه
التطورات الامنيه ناهد يوسف العربيه بيروت